hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to dungeon nightmares
it is dark I don't have a flashlight but
that says proceed to use and now it says
press B to blow she's coming do I need
to press B to blow hi I'm gonna call you
boney
you want me to press B to blow I
wouldn't look in the mirror where's the
mirror you just lost your beatable uh
privileges don't follow her to that room
oh really
did she hear about my B to blow skills
you know that red text when it says
artifact is found makes me think that I
might die soon I might die soon no thank
you
be the same boney as the other boney I
got to turn around open this door I was
so hideously ugly that the second I
looked at him he died why why do I keep
blacking out for those I proceeded to
use and now it says press B to blow
really it's also for butts which I'm
gonna stab of the maker of this game I'm
gonna stab them in the butt stupid
starts dammit dammit this is a violent
game